i loved the first season
so i am happy that i can say i love the
second season
as well thank you so much thank you
these characters
and the show are so fun and
i'm curious for both of you i mean
because this show was not
based on source material and no one knew
who these characters would be or what to
expect from them the audience went into
the first season with no expectations so
when did you realize how much of a
success the show had become
and that it was connecting with
audiences globally
probably like right after the trailer of
season one came out like before the show
even came out
when the promos and the trailer came out
all of our followings skyrocketed
and we were all getting messages from
people saying that they were
dying to see the show and this is
exactly the kind of show they've been
waiting for their whole lives and um
when i saw the response we're getting
just from the trailer i was like okay
this
hopefully it lives up to its
expectations but this is something that
is
clearly so special and so needed right
now and then of course when the show
came out and it
you know became a global success almost
overnight it was
just so incredible and such an honor for
us as
being part of this show for me it was
when white
people pronounced our names correctly
like the risk the level of respect
and the level of like trying to you know
get
something right because we our names are
so
butchered it's not even funny like i i
respond to
anything that sounds vaguely starts with
a p
um so when they really took the time
it real i really felt like god the show
must have really
resonated like they must have thought it
was an important show you know
um we were all in quarantine so we i i
certainly had no
fan interaction at all except for
obviously instagram but there were
definitely a couple of
comments which really made me understand
that people were watching
things very differently like the fact
that the south asian dad that mohan
shows up as a loving
presence in devi's life and a present
parent
i didn't even pick up on that uh when
when in the writing but people were just
yearning to be seen and to see
different different representations of
what south asians could look like
there is something for everyone in the
show it's easy to find
something and someone to connect to what
do you most connect to with
it is it something directly related to
your own character is it something
related to something else on the show
i would say i relate to kind of a
combination
of all of the families characters um you
know
unlike kamala i did not grow up in india
i grew up here more like baby
but that being said there's so much with
gamma that i do relate to as a young
south asian woman
you know who did feel a lot of pressure
to get married and you know
is somebody who feels like you know i i
think both gama and i
feel and i don't know if this is just a
south asian thing but
both of us have really high expectations
of ourselves and we feel like we have to
be the perfect child the perfect
sibling the perfect whatever it is that
we set out to do and
um you know and we are both really
ambitious and we go after what we want
but then at the same time we have this
disease to please and i think that
is kind of a cultural thing where we
feel like we have to fulfill
these expectations and make people happy
but that gets in the way of our own
happiness
um but then i also completely related to
so much of baby's character you know
growing up in this country and
you know she says it in the first season
you know somebody says i'm not
indian enough and then the other person
says i'm too indian but all i want to do
is eat a donut and i have felt that way
many times in my life
i agree i i find a lot of myself in
a lot of characters i am nothing like
melanie
in real life and yet there's something
about like
melanie is ancient for me you know it is
how
it's it's the non-sequiturs that my
mother spells it's what my you know the
way that my stepfather used to speak and
my
uncles which make no sense and you know
um
the thing that i did with a character is
say the lines really quickly
like everything comes out of her mouth
really quickly there's no thinking and
you know
she just knows she just knows
parenting advice she just she just knows
it right away she knows what she wants
she knows what she thinks even if it
makes complete
it's nonsensical um and you know it's
just that it's kind of a
kind of parent the south asian parenting
that there's no middle ground there's
zero middle ground you know
and um she's she's she's my aunt she's
my
she's she's my mom she's a composite of
all these
wonderful women that i've grown up with
and i enjoy bringing that aspect
i love that melanie gets a bit of a love
interest this season
and it's in the form of common because
who doesn't want common as a love
interest
so what was it like to give her a
romantic storyline in season
two especially you know she's still
grieving what was it like to get to
play all of that i mean i just wish all
the common scenes were actually for hbo
and so netflix
totally different to be a very different
show
i think just for that section we could
just hop over
um it was wonderful it was so it was so
he's so hot and so nice and so like
generous and so compassionate um
i really never uh you know never quite
met someone like him and
it was wonderful to be acting opposite
him
and i think dr vishal kumar and dr
jackson i you know i didn't realize that
until common stepped into the role
that melanie
feels seen probably for the first time
uh in a way that even mohan couldn't
professionally you know she values
what she does so much and here's dr
jackson was like god you did that i'm
jealous you did that
um and so um i i loved exploring that
aspect of where i hope there's a lot
more
where that came from how did you find
him
as a scene partner because i mean i'm
telling you
i i probably have a like
if i dig down deep enough i probably
have a hard time with goodbyes
you know i as a child i moved around and
saying i was like
terrifying but the scene where i
break up with uh with common i mean it's
not because it's common
like it would make any woman weep
breaking up but the thing i have to say
goodbye uh to dr jackson was a
excruciatingly hard scene for both of us
to to um to film i mean the whole crew
was crying
every take it was just there was this
possibility that melanie could have a
little joy
and just she no one's ready you know the
show is
about how do you move forward and not
necessarily move on
um and it's an exploration of that
aspect of grief and it was
it was really it was really
heartbreaking to shoot that beautiful
scene
yeah there's something so centered about
him that it's it just
it's such an interesting balance to her
yeah exactly
visha i love that kamalas
is really sort of having the same issue
in her professional life as she's having
in her
personal life she's learning how to
stand up for herself
and speak up about what she actually
wants what was it like for you to go
on that journey with her as she found
her own voice in both
aspects of her life well it's definitely
something that i would say
i'm as a person in real life also uh on
a journey with you know learning how to
use my own voice and to take up space
and to
not be afraid to ask for what i deserve
and for what you know
what i want um so there was a lot of
catharsis happening with playing
uh tamla in this season and um i think
it was it was a journey for both of us
but i i just thought it was
so much fun to do this because you know
season one
she's more there as a foil to the baby's
character whereas in this season she's
learning to be
more like baby and to channel her own
inner rage and
be a badass and be a rebel uh just like
baby is so
it was so much fun and um i hope we get
to see more of that if
if and when we have a season three at
the end of the season we see her
literally run away from the life that
she's expected to live
yeah so what what do you hope is next
for her
i mean she shows up at teacher karaoke
but we don't know
where that goes from there yeah we don't
know where that goes by the way
yeah uh yeah we don't know where i don't
i don't know where it's going to go
but um i don't think that she ran away
because
you know she's over prashanth and she
doesn't want to be with him anymore i
think it was just
all of the pressure she's been feeling
um
collectively from her work and from this
relationship and from her family
it's just getting to a boiling point
where she just she's already lost her
[ __ ] at the lab and now she's still
i think she's still like kind of on a
high or on an adrenaline rush from that
and she's like i'm just gonna i'm gonna
mess everything up now
and she gets a little bit of confidence
from you know when she loses her
[ __ ] at the lab so um i i don't know i
don't know where it's going to go but i
hope
to see her um be able to just
make decisions for herself and continue
on this path of using her voice and
standing up for herself and what she
wants
i just love that moment of her literally
running away because like who hasn't
thought about doing that at some point
and she did it it's so great that come
on of all people
ended up doing it in a fully plaid
sorry and jewelry and
a lot of heaviness happening and
barefoot because she's barefoot when
she's at home so when we filmed it i
think i think
we had as a character choice she grabs
house slippers so she runs away in her
house slippers and sorry and goes to
karaoke night
do you guys have your own personal wish
list of what you would like to see
still with your characters things you
would like to learn about them or
explore with them
i would love to see actually for both
melanie and gama i would love to see a
flashback of
when melanie well we kind of already saw
this with melanie but i guess more so
for kamala then uh i would
love to see a flashback of come up
before she moves to the us and
her family i would love to see who her
family is and why she is the way that
she is
and you know she mentions in season two
that she has three sisters i would love
to meet her sisters and see
what they're all about and you know if
they're like baby or if they're more
like gumla
um yeah just to see more of kamla's
backstory i think would be awesome
my ideas would be so incipit next to
what the writers come up with it's one
of the most brilliant writer's room i
have
ever come across in my entire life so
what they have cooking for us
and you know is is 100 times i i too
like richa
would love to see what mohan and noni's
life
was like you know when when before baby
was born
or as baby was a child i'd love to
understand how melanie
um you know her work-life balance is
this gorgeous scene between
mohan and nalani where mohan cannot
support her
at an award ceremony he's unable to
because he's so insecure
like what that ex just explored that
dynamic uh
more and uh yeah that's what i'd love
john mcenroe narrates davey's life if
you
could have any famous person narrate
your life would you
huh mindy kaling she said it before i
could
say the same thing i'm just
trying to sabotage rachel okay fine if i
had to say somebody else
strictly because of the voice i just
love her voice it's scarlett johansson
because when she did her i just
loved her voice it seems like mindy
would definitely have some good insight
to add if she were narrating both of
your lives
yeah she's a great she's a great uh
voiceover artist and her comedic timing
is unmatchable
and she's so she's so different from
both melanie and camilla so the contrast
would be
hilarious is there a quality in your
character that you wish you had
oh kamal's just so nice obviously she
has you know her limits and her
boundaries and
we see more of that in season two but
she's just such a nice
optimistic she's the kind of person that
truly sees the glass half
half full half half full uh so i would
love
i would love to have a little bit of
more of that quality in my life
you know nomi really holds it together
and she can you know she can she is um
she's she's strict but she she really
holds it together she
doesn't like to show emotion and i um
a lot of times it's really hard for me
to speak because i get so emotional so
i i like that quality of hers i wish i
had a little bit more of that
well i i love these characters i love
the show they're so fun i always
when i watch it i feel like if davey
doesn't want to be at family dinner i'll
come join them i mean they just seem
like
they'd be the most fun so the food is
always great too
yeah it seems like if she doesn't want
to have a good time i'll
go hang out with her family so come join
us come join us
we really we really will thank you so
much
thank you nice to meet you